Kelly Clarkson it's a very important
story involving Kelly Clarkson she
suggested to me
that all of this confusion this personal
confusion this political confusion that
we're dealing with
that a lot of it probably owes to the
breakdown of the American Family Kelly
Clarkson I guess is divorced and she's
got two kids and she described it quite
honestly
how that divorce is affecting her kids I
literally asked my kids every night when
we're snuggly and I put in bed I'm like
are you happy yeah and like if you're
not like what could make you happier no
that's it they always say yes no like
sometimes they'll say especially the
like past two years like a lot of it and
it kills me but they'll and I want them
to be honest so I I don't ever say oh
God don't tell me that you know
um but a lot of times it would be like
you know I'm just really sad you know I
wish Mommy and Daddy were in the same
house I wish and they're really honest
about it and that's and I'm raising that
kind of individual I want you to be
honest with me I won't be getting
married but like forever no like in my
life you know I've been through a couple
divorces my own family like as a kid and
it's like
to me you can be in love I would I would
love to fall in love like I would love
to find someone and fall in love and do
that thing but I I have children and
that's why I say
it's very sad that she's divorced it's
horrible for the kids
I don't support divorce I don't support
actual divorce in any circumstance
because I don't I don't think that it is
real I think that what God has joined no
man can separate and uh there and even
just in practice even if you're not that
religious if you are married and you
have children and you get divorced
you're still married even forget about
the sacramental aspect you're just
practically speaking still married
you're going to be talking to your ex
husband or wife all the time you're
going to be arranging visitation with
the kids you're going to be arranging
vacations they're going to be coming in
and out of your home very likely so it
just can't happen it just doesn't
actually happen in practice at a in a
terrestrial level or even at a
metaphysical certainly not at a
metaphysical level uh and in some cases
I would support uh separation I think
that would be uh you'd have a right to
that or it might even be necessary
depending on risk and danger and abuse
and all the rest of it but as a as a
matter in principle there's no such
thing as divorce but I give
Kelly Clarkson a lot of credit here for
one thing she said which is
I'm not going to be getting remarried
no I'm not going to be getting remarried
which is the traditional position of
Christian civilization is there's really
no such thing as remarriage in fact part
of the cracking up of Western Christian
civilization was because Henry VII
wanted to get remarried and the pope
said no you can't it's just not possible
I can't even do it even if I wanted to
tell you that you could get remarried uh
while the while the other spouse is
still alive Henry VII
had an answer for that too I guess but
what Kelly Clarkson is saying is no I'm
not going to be just pursuing me uh yes
I'd love to fall in love yes it seems
really nice but I'm not going to do that
my concern is for my children and I'm in
the reality of of this marriage but the
marriage is the fundamental political
institution
so the libs are going to say you're all
fuddy-duddies I can hear oppressive
you're terrible if you want to put any
restrictions on the way that people can
dissolve marriages because they don't
like the cut of their spouse's jib or
something like that but if you don't
deal with marriage if the political
order doesn't take seriously marriage
and the preservation of marriage then
you're gonna you're not going to be able
to preserve your political order because
marriage is the basic political unit
it's not a private matter it's not a
single individual it's a public matter
it involves multiple people
living together that's the definition of
Politics as goes the American family so
goes The American Nation you cannot
believe a thing the libs are telling you
that's our theme today
it's our theme this year for the last
five years
and it's being reflected in the polls
72 percent of Americans say the country
is on the wrong track under Biden this
according to a Monmouth University poll
only 17 percent of Independents believe
that Joe Biden's America is headed in
the right direction
and the most depressing part of that
poll
is that I'm not convinced Biden won't
win re-election
that's the most devastating part of that
poll to me
not just because the poll numbers could
change let's say that this were the day
before general election 2024 Monday
night and that those were the numbers I
still am not convinced that Joe Biden
wouldn't win re-election and you aren't
either
no reason you're not is because
Americans no longer have faith in the
electoral system it's not just
Republicans it's not just the Q Anon far
right-wing fascist stooge Putin loving
whatever
it's the Democrats too the Democrats
actually according to surveys
so take social science with a grain of
salt as you will
the
the Democrats have less faith in our
elections than the Republicans do
so I'm just I'm not I'm not saying
that's right or that's wrong or here's
the evidence that the 2020 election was
stolen or here's the evidence that the
2000 election was stolen or any I'm just
it's just a fact Americans don't trust
the electoral system
and I think it's quite clear that the
system
all political systems are rigged and
imperfect and corrupt to some degree and
in as much as ours is rigged it would
appear to be legged rigged rather toward
the libs the libs have the political
power in the United States
they have the power of
the bureaucracy they've got the power of
the elected government right now almost
all of it they've got the power in the
media they've got the power in big Tech
parent education on and on and on
they've got the power
so when it looks like Trump's going to
be reelected in 2020 they just change
the rules
they win the election that's that's far
more devastating these are these issues
that go a lot deeper than oh is it
Trumper DeSantis
I don't know ooh is Biden going to run
again or is it gonna be Gavin Newsom I
don't know
my question is where's the family going
where where is religiosity in the United
States going John Adams said the country
is built for a moral and religious
people
that that wasn't just a fun line that
wasn't just uh you know a little bit of
pop psychology or something
he's describing an essential character
of The Constitution
as religiosity declines debts of Despair
increase in political stability
increases
what's going on with that
what's going on with our border do we
have a definition as a nation anymore
what's going on with our language do we
know what words mean anymore do we speak
the same language meaning English do we
do we even speak the same English
language do we know what man means do we
know what woman means
sonnets are defined by limits
good poet bad poetry doesn't have any
limits to it it sounds like slam poetry
it's a complete death of art good poetry
like Shakespeare has lots of limits to
it and it's within those limits that you
find that beauty the same is true of
Nations the same is true of all identity
we are defined as much by what we are
not as what we are we can see clearly
what we are when we know what we are not
this is
the topic of my speech tonight at Purdue
if you are around Purdue in Indiana West
Lafayette please come on by I'm told
that there will be not one but two
simultaneous protests of my event I
haven't even finished writing the speech
yet but they're already protesting me I
I've been told that there's a drag show
at one of these protests
and one of the drag performers is named
Annihilation which is kind of funny but
they missed the word the word is
supposed to be eradication not but
anyway they have that performing so it
should be quite a show and then if you
do manage to make it through the crazy
liberal hordes you can get into the
Auditorium and we can talk about what it
means to be an American what it means to
be a man what identity means in 2023 the
rest of the show continues now we have
furries coming up make sure you go to
dailywire.com Knowles use promo code
nulls to check out for two months free
on all annual plans
[Music]
thank you